-Welcome back, everybody.
We're hanging out with
Billy Crystal right now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, Billy, you have
so many great bits
in all the comedy shows
you've done through the years.
But my favorite bit is this one
bit that you do where you take
famous movie posters and you cut
out the mouths of the people
and then --
-You put the lips through.
It's like you do impressions
without having to do
an impression.
-Yeah.
-It's just the mouth.
-The reason why I thought about
it is because today
we recently saw each other
as we were getting
our COVID test here at NBC.
And I remember it so clearly.
-Yeah, it was earlier today.
-Go ahead and take a seat.
We'll call you shortly.
-Great, thanks.
-Hey!
-Billy.
Great to see you.
-How you doing?
Long time.
-Yeah.
You're already dressed
for the show.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, me too.
I'm also miked for the show
as well.
What do you think? No masks?
-No masks.
That's good because I actually
got tired of my breath
smelling like I ate cat food.
-Yeah, I hear you.
Did you get your booster yet?
-Booster? Um...
Actually, I don't know,
you know.
I don't know.
I got -- I got my booster,
you know,
on the day of
my daughter's wedding.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
Oh, no, no.
Oh, oh, no way, man.
Oh, no, no!
That is so cool, Marlon Brando.
No way.
-You know,
you don't have to do that.
You're very pretty.
-Oh, no, I can't believe
you said that I'm pretty.
Why would you do that?
-Listen, if you would talk
that fast,
I would have been able to
watch all of "Dune."
[ Laughter ]
-Listen here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Listen here, Mac.
You think gas is a problem now.
We used to have to fill our cars
up back in my day with steam.
They were all steam engines.
[ Laughter ]
I remember Mom --
Mom used to say --
[ Laughter ]
Mom used to say all the time --
would say, "Joey, Joey, don't
spend hours hocking loogies
into the side of the truck."
Head over to the sock hop
to get root beer salad.
-Yeah, yeah, salad.
Yeah. Yeah.
I like, you know, yeah.
Yeah, salad.
I got -- I got twins, twins.
I got to buy two salads
for the twins, you know?
Two Caesar salads.
I got a Cesar Romero salad
and a Julio Cesar Chavez salad.
[ Laughter ]
And yeah, yeah, it's wild.
Twins, yeah.
-Okay, gang, okay, gang, gang,
I don't think that's allowed.
Okay, okay, that's -- Guys, we
can't do that, okay, gang?
Okay, guys, guys, guys,
we can't do that.
Alright? We can't do that.
-Are you telling me
that I can't do that?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Are you telling me
that I can't do that?
I don't think you want to tell
me that I can't do that.
Yeah. No Nobu for you.
No Nobu for you.
-I can't believe --
I can't believe you own Nobu.
That's like the craziest --
You know, 'cause I love sushi
and I didn't even know --
I took Sandy to the beach,
you know.
We get like -- catch a fish
and go get some sushi, right?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Mr. Crystal?
They're ready for your tests.
-Oh. Thank you.
-Mult-- Tests?
Multiple tests?
-Yeah, I'm also getting
a colonoscopy.
[ Laughter ]
It was a two-for-one sale.
And actually...
It was an offer
I couldn't refuse.
-Absolutely,
why would you do that?
You don't have to do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love you, buddy.
That was so great.
That's Billy Crystal
right there. Come on.